- Angela Merkel demeure
jusqu'à la formationd'un gouver.
Elle mène la lutte contre
la pire vague connue son pays j.
"C'est un jour très triste,
dit-elNoNoNous déplorons
100 000 victimes du coronavirus
et, malheureusement,momomomomomr
s'y ajoutent en ce moment."blblt
des restrictions strictes.
Les non-vaccinés, plus de 30 %
de la population, n'ont plus
aux restaurants, qui sont
carrément fermssss
certaines régions.
Le premier ministre tchèque
décrète l'état d'urgence
connaît un des plus haut taux
de contagimomomomonde :
25 000 nouveaux cas par jour
cette semaine.s s s s s s s s se
la population, n'ont plus accès
aux endroits publics comme
les bars et restaurants,
Et tous les marchés de Noël
resteront fermés.
En Slovaquie, une explosion
de cas et d'hospit u u u u u u .
Bars, restaurants et magasins
non essentiels sont fermés
pour deux semaines.
ouvertes, pour l'instant.
"Il aurait fallu être
plus strict, dit ce Slovaque
et fermer aussi les écoles."
OLIVIER VÉRAN, ministre,
- À compter de demain,un décretu
obligatoire le port du masque
partout enececececececececececee
pas, mais on resserre
certaines mesures sanitaires.
20 000 nouveaux cas ont été
de dimanche. Comment explique-t-
on cette 5e vaunununununun pays
qui a pourtant une bonne
couverture vaccinale?
76 % des Français sont vaccinés,
75 % des Canadiens le so
MIRCEA SOFONEA, épidémiologiste,
- Il y a des situations,
dededededede l'Ouest, qui sont
dues à un relâchement des gestes
barrières et àicicicicicicicici,
avec le temps.
Dre CÉCILE TREMBLAY, microbiol.-
- Oui, on devrait s'inquiéter.
Parce qu'àa a a a a a toujours
suivi ce qui s'est passé
en Europe, à quelques semaines
nettement dans une 5e vague
avec un nombre accru non
seulement de cas, mais de décès
inquiétant, d'autant plus que
le phénomène, ususususususussi
aux États-Unis. Ils sontsésésésé
leurs cas. Ils sont rendus,
eux aussi, dans une 5e vague.
- En France, tous les adultes
auront accès à une 3e dose
du vaccin à compter de samedi
baisse d'environ 20 %, six mois
apprprprprprprpremières doses.
- On voit, de plus en plus,
l'immunité baisse avec le temps
dans toute la population, pas
juste dans cette catégorie-là.
à mon avis, ça va nous prendre
e e e e e e e e de vaccin
pour rehausser ce niveau
d'immunité-là.
- Pour tout le monde?
- À mon avis, ç t t t t t t t t.
- Pour l'infectiologue,
la 5e vague est déjà à
nos portes et les gouvernements
une 3e dose du vaccin
grgrgrgrgrgrgrgroupes d'âge.
Ici Sophie Langlois